象牙が始まる前にいや強度とかもすごい動画だと思うんですけども
最後にすごいプレゼントのキャンペーン頑張っておりますので皆さんよかったら最後
まで見てください
同じですこんにちははじめ社長です今日はスペシャルなゲストが切っていただいており
ます
こちらはタグを付け金子さんデー
hao
果汁をんして高槻金子でよろしくお願いしまーす
焼いてこれ
[拍手]
ブーブーボケッ25でし1990
3年生だよねーうわぁ
はい行きで今日はですね高月さんと非常に多すぎるんですけど
こんな僕と良かったらオレンジっていうあはい
すごい有名な先があるんですよ
もしよかったら一緒に読んでいただきたいと
ええええええですか犬ショッカー
a 4 re
オレンジちなみにどうやってご存知もちろん世界みました
実はですねここ最近全部よあーじゃあねー
あったよ本当に感動しますともうめちゃくちゃ感動しますよね
最後のぷるぷるでしたもやめっちゃいい咲くんですけれども
オレンジの一部のシーンをと高月さんと僕で当たり
そして読みたいと思いますよ
作れますもうなんかある意味しましょう漫画っぽく言うかもう見つめ合うところはもう
イッターってなるべく高分がっぽくないが遠くね中も頑張って感情を込めていくんぬー
宜しくお願いします7月15日つつじ祭さ
鮪
今日も諏訪は私とかかりを代わってくれて開けると私を2人にしてくれた
かけると二人になるとやっぱりどうしても緊張してうまく話せ
暇つぶしに質問していい那覇はさ
スバと挙げたくと
俺の3人の中で
告白されるなら
誰に一番を隠さ
hey
ナンです卒中に
ata
きっ
決められない
じゃよ
俺に気を使わず
a そうじゃなくてそんなの誰が一番かなんて勇気持ってるけど
ヒールわけない絶対
叩けばわーうちら女子3人の中で告白するなら誰がいい
ねええええ
言わない
さあ
たよねー
じゃあましたにいい
そうだね
キキタコっと思う
[音楽]
打法
花火どこで見る
俺もプールがいいかなと思ったへっこんだ
7テレパシー使えるんだん
[音楽]
をかける
米
不足なってごめん
4 p あっこれ今日は絶対つけたいって思っていっ
ありがとう
どんな顔するのかと思うんだ
な方
こないかと思っそうなるっ
絶対クリー
今日釣った楽しみにしてたから
楽しみで昨日よく眠れなかったああ
一緒だっ
あのね
今日かけるが言ってた事本当は決まってるよ
俺が言ってたことん
私
3人の中でああ
健に一番告白された
明が松本に来てくれてうれしいよ
出会えてよかっ
オレはー
3人のなかで
な本に一番告白したいっ
あああああ
[音楽]
宇治市
うれしい
俺も分身
どうじょえっっ
消え air
だぞ
今日
来てくれてありがとう
一緒に花火が見れていうかな
[音楽]
今日は俺
衣装はせない
今日は
[音楽]
par
ここすごいですよねオレンジの中でも重要なシーンなんで実は何です
はいでここでちょっとオレンジの作品をかけて紹介してみましょう
まずですねこの話未来から手紙が届くことから始まります
未来未来カーで未来からですちょっとぶっ飛んでるように見えるんですけどこれが
すごい子
ブーブーますイードンっ
結局は
事故死事故で亡くなっちゃっています10年後にその
っていう未来がわかった状態で話が進んでいきます
そしてかけるが現状未来を変えるために主人公たちが運命を変えていくという話になっ
ております
敗2分けでオレンジ続きが気になる方はぜひ
なんか異様な下にありますこちらからダウンロードして読んでみてください
入って上で今日読んだぺトマトいうアプリなんですけどもなんとオレンジのほかにも
10名作品が期間限定で0円で読めちゃいます
moi
そしてなんとピッコマですね広告がないのですごい読みやすい
そしてですね期間限定で今だけ0円で読める作品なんですけども
となりの怪物くん物群君の膵臓を食べたい
試しペダルあーーやピラーちはやふる桜などが今だけ強いんだよじゃあ
今すぐご井崎0位そしてなんと最後にプレゼントキャンペーンのお知らず零封
1こまをダウンロードしてくれた人の中から抽選で
肇社長のサイン入りぴっこまあオリジナル図書カード5000円分を10名様に
プレゼントいたします
いい
10名様です詳しい応募条件はどんなの概要欄からチェックしてみてください
皆さんたくさんの応募お待ちしておりますばいばいばいばーい
me
ございますありがとうございます
ありがとうございます